tout ici est dédié à la ferronnerie
d'art jusqu'aux poignées des portes
l'antre de françois daverat est une
forme de cathédrales hauteur sous
plafond 7 un impressionnant bestiaire
plus de 700 oeuvres l'artiste est un
précurseur de la cause animale
prenez par exemple ces pieuvres géantes
70 kg d'acier pâtit
plus vrai que nature
j'ai voulu exprimer nos mouvements le
mouvement avec de l'acier qui d'habitude
est inerte et là j'ai voulu le faire
bouger le plus difficile c'est
naturellement de transcrire le mouvement
des tentacules les détails des
tentacules et tout ça bon s'est créé
avec de la soudure et des tôles de 4 mm
embouti au marteau et sous 2 dans ses
galeries tard un personnage intrigue
fascinante et réalisme c'est le parterre
d'eau il ploient sous la charge
écrasé par la vie le porteur d'eau hors
de l'eau à bout de bras et au terme de
son périple il voit ses bras qui se
transforme en joue que c'est une
métamorphose
c'est aux royalistes et l'eau est
précieuse donc se transporte dans des
jarres en bronze
et de voiliers de le personnage pnc il
avance c'est un mais
le chemin est difficile c'est la vie
plus loin dans la galerie à cheval et
nice chargé de kelis ans imite afin
la signification c'est le fait que la
les sciences
les
et là évoluent à une vitesse
comparable à celle du cheval au galop ce
que vous voyez en 1 m 40 de long je le
fais en quatre mètres 50 devant la
mairie de maisons d'un foot passer par
la prestigieuse école parisienne bull
françois lavera a réalisé plus de 70
sculptures monumentales un coq en inox
près de six mètres de haut bois 2 tonnes
l'envol en acier inox 17 mètres de haut
[Musique]
un marteau que j'ai personnaliser un
petit peu pour qu'il soit plus résistant
mais le point faible c'est qu'il est de
plus en plus lourd parce que je remets
du métal à chaque fois et on a nos là
les pinces qui datent du 19e siècle qui
sont là pour faciliter la vie du
forgeron donc depuis les années
1890 dans son atelier françois lavera
aime tant se confronter avec la matière
un corps à corps exigent une étreinte à
l'issue incertaine
c'est plus qu'un dialogue c'est un
combat c'est un combat singulier entre
l'artiste et la matière et il faut
arriver à transformer cette sacrée
matière pour en sortir la quintessence
imprimer un petit peu de vie à
l'intérieur de cette matière un peu de
soi mais ça demande un combat sa demande
se mesurer à l'adversité à 60 ans dont
40 consacré à cette passion qui le tient
au corps françois a toujours le feu
sacré ce dont je suis le plus fier c'est
toujours ce que j'ai fait en 16 es
toujours la sculpture à venir sauf que
bon ski ffs est intéressant mais le
mieux c'est ce que l'on va faire c'est
toujours dans le projet dans l'avenir
c'est ce qui est cette forme de lumière
que l'on cherche toujours à atteindre il
est perpétuellement devant soi dans ses
jardins une oeuvre éléphantesque qui n'a
pas encore trouvé d'acheteur 7 m 2 4 2
le point 2 tonnes le titre porté
l'avenir
il s'agit d'un appel pressant à
préserver un écosystème mise à mal par
l'activité humaine